frank agarro un resfriado contagioso el
día siguiente va a la escuela y tres de
sus compañeros se resfrían por la misma
enfermedad
cada día posterior a este el número de
personas que se resfrían se triplica se
hace el número de personas que se
resfrían al día t es una función lineal
o una función exponencial y bueno
recordemos una función lineal a lo que
se refiere es en este caso que cada día
se van a resfriar la misma cantidad de
personas es decir tres en el primer día
se van a resfriar tres en el segundo día
se van a resfriar otros tres en el
tercer día otros tres sin embargo eso no
es cierto con estos datos que me dan
porque me dicen que cada día posterior a
ese el número de personas que se resfría
se triplica y cuando estoy diciendo que
algo se triplica a lo que me refiero es
que tiene un factor de 3 y de hecho lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera
primero se resfría
después se resfrían tres de sus
compañeros pero el siguiente día se van
a resfriar nueve compañeros se va a
triplicar estos tres y entonces en el
cuarto día se van a resfriar 27 y así
sucesivamente hasta podemos decir que el
modelo de esta función es 3 elevado a la
cantidad de días 3 elevado a la t por lo
tanto estamos hablando de una función
exponencial y como es una función
exponencial vamos a ver cuál de estos
sencillos me habla de la función
exponencial que estamos trabajando en
este momento el primer inciso dice la
función es lineal o no no es lineal
entonces creo que está esta no es mi
respuesta correcta
esta función es lineal pues otra vez
función lineal amplio que esto no me
sirve esta función es exponencial ok
hasta aquí vamos bien pues se multiplica
por un factor de tres cada vez que te
incrementa en uno ok
esta es una respuesta correcta porque
cada vez que nosotros aumenta
el tiempo en 1 es decir pasa un día
nuestra cantidad de enfermos se
multiplica por un factor de 3 3 927
etcétera por lo tanto esta es una buena
opción y vamos a revisar solamente que
el último inciso no nos diga también
otra respuesta correcta esta función es
exponencial hasta ahí vamos bien pues se
se incrementa en seis a medida que te
aumenta de 1 a 2 eso no es cierto es una
función exponencial porque tenemos un
factor de 3 aunque en este caso si se
incrementa en 6 a medida de que te
aumenta de 1 a 2 no es la razón por la
cual se es una función exponencial por
lo tanto yo creo que esta es la única
respuesta correcta así que vamos a
intentar ver si es la respuesta correcta
y de lujo estamos bien así que vamos a
hacer un siguiente problema
james está organizando una fiesta en la
hacienda de su familia visita así
conmigo personalmente y los invito a la
fiesta
aquí creo que vamos bien le pide a cada
uno de esos cinco amigos que visite e
invite personalmente a cuatro de sus
amigos a la fiesta el día siguiente y
que le pida a cada uno de sus amigos que
visite e invite personalmente a cuatro
de sus amigos el día siguiente y así
sucesivamente se apee el número de
personas que reciben una invitación
personalmente a la fiesta de jane el día
de supón que los cuatro amigos invitados
cada día por cada persona no han
invitado a nadie más
ok espero una función lineal o una
función exponencial y bueno vamos a
pensar un poco este problema fíjate bien
si james visite primero a cinco amigos
personalmente ok le va a pedir a cada
uno de estos cinco amigos que visite
personalmente a cuatro de sus amigos en
el día siguiente por lo tanto en el
segundo día la cantidad de invitados va
a ser 5 por 4 es decir 20
invitados va a ver a la fiesta en la
hacienda de su familia si te das cuenta
el primer amigo invita 4 el segundo
invita a 4 y así cada uno de estos 5
amigos pero después lo que les pide
james es que cada uno de estos nuevos
cuatro invitados invite a cuatro amigos
de manera personal por lo tanto en el
tercer día vamos a tener cinco por
cuatro los cuales 20 ya esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por cuatro porque cada uno
de los invitados va a invitar a cuatro
amigos más ok entonces como estamos
multiplicando por un factor de 4 parece
que estamos hablando de una función
exponencial que por cierto tiene un
factor de 4 así que veamos nuestras
respuestas es una función lineal no es
una función lineal tampoco es una
función exponencial hasta ahí vamos bien
pues ps multiplica por un factor de
cinco no estamos multiplicando por un
factor de 4 porque al día siguiente
vamos a invitar cuatro amigos más al día
siguiente otros
y por lo tanto esta es una función
exponencial pues ps multiplica por un
factor de 4 cada vez que te aumenta en 1
esta es mi respuesta correcta y es hora
de comprobar la respuesta vamos a ver si
estamos bien y de lujo estamos bien nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo